One Night in March 2023 in the Central
African Republic security cameras
captured a group of men hurling Molotov
cocktails over the fence of a brewing
facility owned by French multinational
Castell one of the largest beverage
conglomerates in the world
Western intelligence agencies would
later confirm that the Wagner group was
responsible for the attack that
destroyed a large portion of the
brewery's stock
the arson wasn't a random act of
vandalism it was part of a larger War
for influence in Africa between Russia
and the West
in the Central African Republic beer
matters to Wagner because French brands
have a large presence in their former
Colony
since the 1990s Castel has produced a
beer called mocaf in the Central African
Republic
the mocraft brewery has been one of the
largest employers in the country's
limited industrial sector
one year prior to the arson attack
Wagner broke ground on a competing
Brewery North of the capital bangi they
rapidly scaled up production and
distribution of their own beer brand
called Africa tilor which is sold as
Russian
Castell was able to keep producing its
mocaf beer throughout cir Civil War but
not without controversy
in 2021 a report by the investigative
non-profit group the century detailed
how Castel protected its business
interests ncar by making cash payments
to Rebel groups like The Union for peace
or UPC
astel did not respond to requests for
comment but in the past they've denied
these payments were criminal and that
they fueled the conflict
using the details in the report Wagner
saw an opportunity to sell its narrative
about the role of the French as
exploitative colonizers in the country
in January 2023 a group of social media
accounts began simultaneously spreading
the same message
Castel supports terrorism
one meme spread by the campaign depicted
bottles of mocaf loaded into an assault
rifle with the message each bottle
purchased is a bullet in the gun of
Bandits
disinformation experts the journal spoke
to confirmed these accounts were
connected to Wagner and said the
campaign Bears the Hallmarks of one of
Wagner's online influence operations
Wagner's campaign also used offline
means of spreading this message like
Billboards and flyers one flyer read
with each Castel purchase you fund the
war and kill yourself
the group also organized demonstrations
where protesters poured out bottles of
mocap while holding signs about Castel
support for armed groups
the protests were Amplified by
wagner-funded social media accounts and
news outlets
Wagner used its existing network of
businesses to supply build and staff its
Brewery
most Wagner businesses in car are
centered on natural resources like gold
diamonds and Timber
Africa tea lore represents a shift for
Wagner into businesses that engage with
the public
selling Russian beer to Central Africans
provides an opportunity to sell a
positive image for Russia's role in the
country
many of the same accounts that took part
in the campaign against Castell now tout
Africa tilor as an alternative
representatives for Wagner and Africa
tillore did not respond to requests for
comment
[Music]
Wagner's message about Castel mirrors
its broader message that the French
exploited the country and contributed to
its violence and that Russia and Wagner
are here to help services
across Africa Wagner has organized
demonstrations and social media
campaigns promoting Russia as an
alternative to France and the West
[Music]
since the attack Castel has continued to
produce its beer in car
and Wagner's future role in the country
appears to be in flux after the death of
its leader yevgeny pagosian
but their presence remains deeply
ingrained
foreign